you  [Music]  you have interrupted a citywide  investigation you stole evidence from my  crime scene  and you got my one lead killed I was  trying to help him but you didn't Joseph  stop talking who the hell are you  My name is Matthew Murdock I'm your  attorney  [Music]  how does being Harlem's hero allow you  to live an actual life right now that's  what I help people  I think there's someone you need to meet  hey what are you doing in there pal who  you who you how come she can't be hurt  what's the deal with that's this I'm the  immortal I'm just you Wow you're on the  same side you for the devil of Hell's  Kitchen the smartass detective we got a  problem  the righteous X Cohen yeah mother and  the kid with the growing fish the war  for New Yorkers here so get your [ __ ]  together more connections you have  you're okay to preach it looks like an  idiot  your scarf  we make quite a team  now are you talking about Boyd poor  blind ninja whatever it is you are  classy  you